many children across the english-speaking world
grew up hearing mother goose nursery rhymes about
mice running up clocks old women living in shoes
and one unfortunate egg by the name of humpty
dumpty but have you ever heard the rhyme about the
crooked man most of us who heard that particular
poem remember it like this there was a crooked man
and he walked a crooked mile he found a crooked
sixpence against a crooked style he bought a
crooked cat which caught a crooked mouse and
they all live together in a little crooked house
a little bit odd but hey most nursery rhymes are
when have you ever seen a little girl sitting on
a tuffet eating some curds and whey what even is a
tuffet honestly what are curds and whey let's just
move on residents of the sleepy english hamlet of
tembi and oxfordshire hear a more menacing version
of the rhyme about the crooked man sung as a song
on playgrounds shared in hushed tones when the
grown-ups aren't listening it goes like this
there lived a crooked man who made a crooked deal
he kept a crooked cane and his catch in crooked
creel he stole a crooked child who cried a crooked
squeal and that crooked little man was broken
on the wheel it sounds just as inscrutible as any
other nursery rhyme but there is a dark tone to it
that seems a bit out of place especially when you
compare it to the other somewhat cheery version
this creepy alternative to the crooked man nursery
rhyme seems to only be found in the town of tembi
and unfortunately for the residents of that
town there is a deadly truth behind its words
many years ago the scp foundation became aware
of a mysterious pattern in this unassuming town
every 12 years over a period of roughly 70 days
something horrible would happen to townspeople
who happened to be alone and indoors after dark
when they were discovered by a neighbor a family
member a friend or even the police they would be
unresponsive suffering from full-body paralysis
or appearing to be effectively brain dead
this was not the most unusual aspect of the
phenomenon though the victims were all grotesquely
transformed their long bones covered in dozens of
compound fractures combined with excess cartilage
and osseous tissue their limbs would become
distended stretched and deformed into long gnarled
appendages like the limbs of an ancient tree
one of the recovered victims had a forearm
measured at over 2.4 meters long another had
to be placed in a specially outfitted hospital
bed as his spine and legs had stretched to the
point where he was 12.5 meters tall local police
and doctors alike were left scratching their heads
what had happened to these people clearly
something horrible had been done to them
but there was no actual evidence of a crime no
one had been murdered and there was no evidence
of forced entry at any of the victims homes there
was however one other piece to the crooked puzzle
just before a victim was found their place of
residence would visibly degrade and warp the
structure itself breaking in places until portions
collapsed in or became slanted roofs would tilt at
an unsafe angle chimneys would fold over and door
frames would twist until no ordinary person could
pass through them safely this happened every
12 years for decades and none of the people of
tembe could do anything about it in fact they
rarely ever so much as spoke of it terrified
of admitting the truth of their town's curse in so
many words instead they spoke about the phenomenon
in innuendo meaningful glances and pleas to keep
loved ones company at night and through a simple
children's rhyme one doctor tasked with treating
survivors of the horror decided to do something
as the 12 year mark began to approach once more he
reached out to a researcher he had known years ago
a man who specialized in the unexplained things
that modern medicine had no answer for this man
had left medicine behind and was now working
for the scp foundation at the time of contact
there were approximately six months to go until
the phenomenon would begin to strike once more
the foundation needed to act quickly
in order to collect more information
and hopefully find a way to stop the terror
of tembi once and for all with about a month
to go until the danger would reappear a member of
d-class personnel referred to as d-209 was placed
in a foundation-owned house in town audio and
visual equipment were installed throughout the
house in order to monitor it for any anomalous
activity and to make sure d-209 remained at his
post for the first month of his stay d-209 did
not experience anything unusual he spent his
time drinking tea baking pies and catching up
on his reading he even thanked the foundation
for the unexpected staycation unfortunately on
his 43rd day in tembi things changed as d209 sat
in bed reading a novel by the lamplight the camera
feed in the living room began to glitch a vertical
distortion appeared with a jagged pattern that
began to make its way across the room from the
front door it was as if something was coming
inside but the camera could not pick up its
image the distortion continued through the hallway
until the camera placed there cut out entirely
suddenly closed his book as the sound
of scratching came from the floor below
he began to slowly climb out of bed listening
for further sounds as the entity continued to
make its way through the house toward him movement
was apparent on the video feed but there was too
much interference for any image of the creature to
be made out d-209 froze in his tracks as he heard
footsteps slow and certain coming up the stairs
toward him he ran to the window attempting to pry
it open and make an escape but it would not budge
with increasing desperation he grabbed his bedside
lamp and threw it at the window attempting
to shatter the glass the lamp broke apart
but the window remained stubbornly intact as he
scrambled for an escape route something knocked at
his bedroom door d-209 called out toward the door
who is it who's there but there was no response
identify yourself still whatever stood on the
other side said nothing holding the remains of
the lamp in one hand as a makeshift weapon d-209
slowly reached for the doorknob and opened the
door with a sudden pop every light bulb in the
vicinity burst including foundation provided
floodlights positioned outside of the house there
was the sound of snapping and then an agonized
scream the camera adjusted to the lack of light
in the room allowing for a clear image of d209
he was wailing and holding his right arm which
appeared to be broken just above the elbow
the arm began to stiffen and elongate
indicating impossibly fast bone growth
screw this you're not taking me i'm getting out
of here alive he yelled running down the hallway
he collapsed as another snapping sound echoed
throughout the hall my legs broken set out please
he called to someone anyone who might be watching
the feed slowly painfully he pulled himself to
his feet he lifted his right arm to the camera
showing that it had been broken again below the
elbow pointing in the opposite direction of the
first break what are you doing help me he screamed
it it doesn't even hurt anymore that can't be
right i don't know what's happening to me as he
continued to yell at the cameras he limped towards
the stairs attempting to make his way down to the
first floor he missed a step lost his balance
and fell all the way down twelve loud snaps were
heard as he went when he landed on the ground his
bones were broken in several other places only to
be immediately set where they had broken as he
screamed he dragged himself into the living room
battling against his own body which had become
something foreign to him his arms were growing
longer now around two meters long and his legs
stretched out of the camera's view presumably into
the hallway suddenly he stopped crawling his eyes
widening no no no no he whimpered before suddenly
being dragged backwards out of the camera's view
due to the presence of the entity interfering
with the cameras all visibility was lost at this
point there was however still a live audio feed
the microphones picked up an hour of snapping
and screaming until d-209 eventually went quiet
then all that could be heard was a wet sucking
sound followed by a thumping meanwhile at the
hospital 27 other victims of the entity were lying
in hospital beds as d209 met his unfortunate fate
all of the hospitalized victims began to
experience seizures at the same time and seized
for several minutes five patients were killed
and two researchers were injured in the chaos
after the incident at the hospital reports
of a seismic event at the edge of town began
to circulate because there had been no actual
earthquake in the area the research team realized
that this disturbance had to be somehow related
to the phenomenon they planned to investigate in
order to learn more about the entity behind it all
which they had now officially designated scp-783
the crooked man a team of personnel were sent
to investigate the site of the seismic event
only to find a group of 10b townsfolk clustered
around the area in a field at the south of town
the crowd refused to let the researchers
through and would not budge until one researcher
agent collins pulled out her firearm and fired a
shot into the air the sound frightened the crowd
and they realized this mysterious foundation
really meant business where the crowd had
been agent collins could see toes unnaturally
long crooked toes poking up out of the ground
they were going to need some help and a lot more
shovels to uncover this mystery by the next day
a dig team had uncovered a mass grave filled with
victims of scp-783 there were dozens of elongated
bodies spread throughout the five meter wide hole
stacked on top of each other with their heads
facing down and their arms outstretched towards
the bottom of the pit their limbs had grown
around each other twisting together to the point
where they could not be removed one at a time
while trying to collect a tissue sample from one
of the bodies researcher singer lost his balance
as the ground beneath him gave way and he fell
he attempted to find a foothold and climb back
up but fell through the gnarled arms and down into
the pit thinking quickly agent collins grabbed a
rope and tied it around her waist she would lower
herself down into the grave and would signal
when she was ready for them to pull her out agent
collins descended into the pit over 20 meters down
before she signaled for the team to pull her
back out then she told them what she had seen
there was something down there the entrance to
another location beneath all of the bodies someone
asked if there was any sign of researcher singer
colin shook her head face growing pale she hadn't
seen him down there he was gone agent collins was
granted a temporary leave of absence and a d-class
d-2172 was selected for further exploration of
the anomalous mass grave he was outfitted with
a retractable harness communication and video
equipment as well as a photo ionization detector
a geiger counter a basic survival kit a firearm
and ammunition d2172 was then lowered into the
pit via a crane after 12 meters of descent there
was no longer any visible light inside the pit
and d 2172 switched on his headlamp a few moments
later d-2172 began tugging on the tether demanding
to be lowered more quickly when asked why he
insisted someone just touched my back at 18 meters
down d2172 began to feel a sense of confusion
and dizziness unable to tell which direction
he was going at this point in the pit gravity
had inverted forcing d-2172 to climb upward
in order to continue moving down as he crossed
into another world there was daylight visible here
again as d2172 climbed out from within the mass
of bodies there he found a seemingly identical
version of the town of tembi he was instructed to
take soil samples and the monitoring researcher
noticed something odd on the video feed there were
marks in the dirt around the grave that appeared
to have been made by fingers pulling across the
ground they decided not to relay this to d2172
after the soil samples came up normal d2172
was instructed to walk to a nearby cottage
and look for any sign of the missing researcher
singer he knocked on the door and with no answer
let himself in he saw no one inside and began to
walk through in the bedroom on the wall there was
a charcoal sketch of a humanoid figure holding
a staff of some kind command ordered him to
approach the drawing but he protested saying he
felt incredibly uncomfortable looking at it he
relented and began to approach but as he did the
quality of the video feed began to degrade until
it was filled with static d2172 was then permitted
to leave the cottage and further explore this
copycat village while walking further into the
village d2172 spotted a work boot on the ground he
picked it up and found it was a match for the one
researcher singer had been wearing he followed the
path to another house the door of which was wide
open he walked inside to find signs of a struggle
an overturned couch and table a hole in the wall
the broken pieces of a lamp scattered on the floor
the kitchen was just as much of a mess and as he
investigated it further he found a pool of blood
on the floor with significant blood splatter on
the walls and counter it looked like someone had
been attacked with a weapon likely a knife indeed
as he looked d 2172 spotted a butcher's block
with only one empty slot the one that should have
held a meat cleaver the investigation led him to
a locked door covered in scratches he broke it
down and nearly fell down the stairs into the
darkened basement instructed to head down into
the basement d-2172 switched on his headlamp
drew his weapon and descended into the darkness
the basement was empty except for a bloody meat
cleaver and a piece of pant leg caught inside an
exhaust vent leading out of the house the pants
resembled those worn by singer before his fall d
2172 peered into the vent for a closer look but
was startled by the sight of something scuttling
out of sight whatever it was it was fleshy and it
was not something he cared to see more of d2172
continued on his expedition walking north and
away from the town limits of tembi somehow in
spite of this he wound back up at the south side
where he had emerged from the pit but something
was different there were no bodies no open grave
and no tethered harness that he had taken off when
he climbed out he was trapped the harness had not
been retracted so where had it gone command could
not determine its exact location but proposed that
d2172 had entered another anomalous area and
was not in fact back where he started he was
instructed to follow the road back retracing
his steps until he wound up at the pit again
as he walked he commented that he had not yet
seen a single living thing in this place then
as he heard the sound of rustling leaves he turned
toward it to find the corpse of an scp-783 victim
he turned back to continue on his way only to see
another victim sprawled across the road he drew
his weapon then listening as the rustling began
again he spun around to look at the body behind
him and found that it had stretched longer growing
closer to him behind him the other body began to
snap as well he turned to fire his weapon and
saw that this other body had stretched its neck
its head at eye level only a meter away from his
own face he fired several rounds but the corpse
did not respond ignoring orders d-2172 took off
running into the woods leaving the road behind
he stopped to catch his breath sat down and
reloaded his firearm after eating a quick mre
and informing command of his whereabouts he set
back off on his journey through the forest after
14 minutes of walking he began to feel movement
under the ground short sharp bursts of motion
reverberating through the earth he could also
hear a thumping sound coming from beneath him
on the video feed command saw what appeared
to be a silver birch tree lifting out of sight
then dropping down back into the forest shaking
the ground on impact d-2172 was instructed to
approach the object as command quickly realized
that this was no tree as he approached another
similar object landed near him he fired his weapon
at it and blood began to dribble from the wound
a scream ringing out high above him not knowing
what else to do he ran as fast as he could
begging for help from command for someone
to do something to get him out of there
as d2172 ran out of the forest making his way
back to town another one of the long pale objects
knocked him onto his back he looked up now able
to see what it was without the trees in his way
when he saw it he couldn't help but scream it was
researcher singer or at least it had once been
researcher singer he had become something else
something unthinkable his body was up in the sky
balancing on enormous impossibly long fingers
the creature that had once been singer shrieked
lifting a finger and preparing to bring it down
on d-2172 he fired several shots but none hit
so again he turned and ran he reached the main
road and kept running tasting bile in the back
of his throat and feeling his lungs begin to burn
he couldn't stop if he stopped the creature would
grab him in those awful fingers and he didn't
want to think about what would happen next
then he saw it the pit the bodies his way
out he sprinted toward the pit almost there
when a screech rang out and a massive finger
knocked him aside the video feed was lost
with only the sound of d2172 screaming and
running away after this d-2172 was considered lost
and attending researcher dr peterson ordered
that the team pull his harness back out agent
collins protested saying they had no evidence of
d2172's death peterson relented and they waited
for the signal eventually it came two tugs on the
tether d-2172 asking to be pulled out but when
they pulled the tether an empty harness emerged
something was caught on it holding it in the pit
as the team tried to draw it out it was d 2172's
hand gripping the harness as hard as it could
the harness broke free from his grasp and his
hand flailed searching for his chance at escape
another d-class rushed to help grabbing a hold of
2172's hand another d-class joined in along with
dr lafayette and private audi and the group worked
together to pull the fallen man from the pit
only as they pulled they realized that only his
arm had come out and it was continuing to come
more and more and more of his arm stretching out
to three meters in length bending and snapping
at gruesome angles they were too late after all he
was already gone despondent the group released him
and he sank back down into the pit with the rest
there is currently no way for the foundation to
remove the crooked man from tembi for containment
instead they must maintain a strong presence in
the town monitoring the community via a temporary
site five this area includes two houses and a
building near the local hospital their foundation
officers will track any signs of scp-783 activity
as well as continue to research the entity's
nature and any potential weaknesses it may have
in the event that scp-783 becomes active all
of its victims must be removed from the site
of the attack their bodies must be incinerated
and they will be added to the case file for now
there is not much anyone can do but wait and see
because the cycle isn't broken yet it's only a
matter of time the crooked man is coming back to
do his crooked deeds be thankful the foundation
knows what everybody needs if you want to stay
yourself protect your muscle flesh and bone then
you'd better heed this warning don't stay home
at night alone now go check out scp-2316 the
bodies in the water and scp-966 sleep killer for
more unsettling anomalies from the scp foundation